Good morning, Transnational Hotel, New York.
How may I help you?
Good morning, this is Tom Sanders.
I'm calling about the special rate for the members of the Global Travel Club.
Does that apply during the holiday season?
It certainly does.
However, please be aware that rooms can only be booked four weeks in advance.
Oh, that's fine.
I just had a couple of questions I'd like to ask before booking.
Of course, what would you like to know?
Actually, yes, I was hoping to unwind a little.
Do you have a spa or gym?
Yes, we do.
We have a 24-hour wellness center with stationary bikes, weight machines,...
...elliptical trainers and treadmills.
We also have a swimming pool and a sauna, which are open from 6:00 a.m. until midnight.
You can find photos and additional information on our hotel website.
Oh, that sounds great.
We also have a hotel spa where you can book massages and various treatments.
Is there a restaurant in the hotel?
There sure is.
Our five-star restaurant opens for breakfast and stays open until the last guest leaves.
There is also a hotel bar, which is open from 5:00 p.m. onwards.
Great, how about internet access?
You can access our wireless connection in your room.
If you don't have a computer with you, you can use our office center,...
...which is equipped with computers, printers and fax and copy machines.
That sounds terrific.
One last question: do you have a conference room?
Yes, we do.
It seats about 50 people.
Fantastic, I just have to double-check my dates before I book my stay.
Wonderful.